hey I'm Jerry O'Connell and I'm here to
answer the internet what is one rumor
true or false you'd want to spread about
yourself well I guess that I'm like a a
very like generous lover I guess I want
that out to her balls I mean I think
it's true I've heard the opposite but
that's none of my business I don't
believe rumors if you could erase one TV
show slash movie from your memory to
experience again what would it be super
rude but I was really looking forward to
that Batman versus Superman I don't want
to offend anyone in the DC Universe or
DC whatever that movie was terrible I
was really looking forward to Batman and
Superman fighting I mean and I'm not
even that huge of a superhero fan but I
was really looking forward to that movie
and it completely it really disappointed
me like on such a intense level it made
me angry I was like in the middle of the
theater like actually like turning
around and being like oh my goodness oh
my goodness is this is this really for
is this for real like being that person
in movie and I know everyone paid like
15 bucks but I was like everybody what
is happening what is happening this is
the best they could do this is it this
is it I've got to tell you even talking
about it just like really angers me I
would just want to erase it you get
offered a billion dollars to never leave
the state of Ohio do you take it hell
yes
Ohio is a gorgeous state I mean amazing
golf courses Cleveland golf hello you
can become a Cavaliers fan you could
become an Indians fan for 1 billion
I would live in Columbus I would never
leave Columbus for the rest of my life
for 1 billion dollars for 1 billion
dollars I would never leave an apartment
inside Columbus for the rest of my life
who would win in a fight in their prime
Michael Keaton or Jon Bon Jovi Michael
Keaton because he was Batman that was
very easy you could fight one person to
death and switch lives of them if you
win who would you want to fight I guess
it would be I guess it'll be Bill Gates
I'd want to fight Bill Gates to the
death and if I win I get to switch lives
in him because you do get all that money
but he's doing a lot of good in the
world so I'd get to continue on with his
legacy how would I kill Bill Gates I
mean I guess I'd have to like it would
have to be like fitting how I did it I'd
choke him out with like a computer cable
I would never kill Bill Gates these are
jokes these are jokes you can have only
one thing for free for the rest of your
life what do you choose I guess I guess
gas man gas is like such a bummer
because there's no like price on gas
there's no like this is the price and
that's it and it just willy nilly they
just raise it and like depending on like
how shady the gas station you go to is
how much the gas is so I always have to
go to Shady gas stations where like
you're bombarded by people who hang out
at Shady gas stations and then the shady
or the gas station the less likely they
are to take credit so you have to use a
debit card and then it's always like
some dudes like hey just give me your
PIN man just give me the pin just just
give me your pin it it's okay it's safe
it's safe
give me the pin it's totally safe so I
guess gas side one for free do you think
there's more porn stars or murders in
the world that's an amazing question
I mean just based on the sheer amount of
like content on the superhighway I would
guess there's more porn stars in the
world you know like murderers obviously
we see them in the news and stuff but I
know you see a lot of I'm gonna say porn
stars there's more porn stars in the
world you get to choose between a sum of
money or world peace how much does that
sum of money need to be in order for you
not to choose world peace the trick
question
if there is an amount of money that can
make for world peace I would want that
amount of money but I'd want a
percentage of that money for as like a
finder's fee for creating world peace so
there would have to be like a commission
I would need a commission for world
peace like I'm an agent so basically I'm
an agent for world peace I am on the
Jerry Maguire of world peace every time
you finish sexy time a song played which
song would you want it to be that's so
easy whoo-hoo there there who then who
[Music]